der ethik
jetzt sind wir live also nochmal alle
zuschauer herzlich willkommen im neuen
jahr immer selben zeit im auto hier zum
trieb seminar und ich werde jetzt gleich
sagen was ihr euch vor
[Musik]
also hier werden da bitte ich was zu
sagen wenn die hausarbeiten das haben
sich gewünscht
dann werde ich mir mitgegeben kurzen auf
die vergangenen sitzungen und dann
machen wir wenigstens eine ganz kürzlich
an sie verschickten mails hatte haben
wir hier einen frei gelegen das heißt
nicht faltig sie müssen immer ein kurzes
aber sie müssen nicht abgeben
sie können dann selbst korrigiert wie
korrigieren genau gemeinsam zusammen
sozusagen eine slide gegeben und diese
kosten
neues quiz und da gebe einen hat alle
bisher behandelten 1
hier ist und wie sie die entscheidung
für die zuschauer und auch auf der app
können sie schon online nehmen aber wir
machen ihn gezielt
also und dann gehen wir über zuständige
streamen also wie schreibe ich für diese
chance haben darauf mit menschen zu
sprechen kommen und ich nur
philosophische hausarbeiten allgemein
sondern beschädigt so verschlossen
bleiben
über die plastische deutsch philosophie
das ist was ganz besonderes weil die
klassischen deutschen philosophie hat
ihre tücken
und diese tücken die bestehen vor allem
darin dass die begrifflichkeiten die
hier verwendet werden sehr eigentümlich
sind werden begriffe umher geschmissen
das absolute und das ich und das nichtig
und intellektuelle anschauen und das
system und so weiter und so fort und
kann dann hören und sehen vergeht
danach schauen wie man die preise so wie
jetzt mehr jedenfalls auch und wir
müssen hier aufpassen dass wir nicht uns
in diesen strudel dieser begriffs
metaphysik dass uns da nicht verlieren
die verstummte sondern dass wir uns
kritisch zu diesen begriffs ungetümen
begriffs ungeheuer verhalten
den zuschauer zum schauen mal sagen ich
glaube dass es am besten die ich habe
mich lange damit beschäftigt und ich
habe jetzt das super tipps für sie
zumindest in meinem seminar ich kann es
jetzt nicht generell sei eine
seminararbeit geld jetzt gerät alles
außer bei über die klassische deutsche
philosophie sorgen ein systematisches
problem im text fokussieren als es mir
gibt es nicht wenn sie jetzt da
ideengeschichtlich hast schmeiße ich sag
mal vor 40 jahren oder so vor 30 jahren
nahm jetzt ein bisschen fies von mir da
kommt der monat doktorarbeiten schreiben
über die intellektuelle anschauen so was
dürfen sie bei mir nicht schreiben ich
bin jetzt ganz strenge neue sie haben
regeln
ich finde dass man so nicht verankert
wenn man nur motive sich anschaut glaube
muss immer um die klassische deutsche
philosophie die hätten weniger betrieben
wird auf der welt in der studie werden
gestrichen
es gibt zwar außerhalb europas gewisses
interesse dafür aus dem in amerika
südamerika auf nordamerika aber
insgesamt steht ist steht es nicht gut
und die ganze spiel zu gehen und wenn
wir gerecht werden wollen wenn sie nicht
in seinem museum stellen sollten wir uns
die anders als in der vergangenheit
glaube dass die interpretation der
klassischen durch iris tourismus auch
schultern eines kasse
diese philosophie heute
das heißt es soll immer wenn wir uns
diese schwere wirklich begriffs starken
texte von uns überlegen was war ein
problem steht dahinter kurz gesagt wie
können sie eine kommilitonin einem
kommilitonen erklären warum sie sich
jetzt damit hebels betrieb des absoluten
also das ist für mich ganz wichtig die
relevanz des systematisch relevanz und
um leser user würden sie dann nachdem
sie dieses problem ich komplett
auszusprechen was wir hier werden können
nachdem sie dieses problem als solches
erkannt benannt haben dann sollten sie
in dieser hausarbeit entlang dieses
textes versuchen dieses problem und
besser gesagt seine lösung zu
rekonstruieren kannst du mir bedeutet
mit anderen als es der autor die kultur
getan hat dazu stellen andere also nicht
im rahmen dieser begrifflichkeit das
wäre nämlich die momente der irritation
da bin ich sehr kritisch also erstmal
alles muss man ja dass es in der welt
virtuell
das ist also ganz wichtig für mich
ich gebe ihnen ja auch gerne zu dass ich
das früher auch immer nichts gemacht ich
konnte mich da auch nicht schnell lösen
davon das wird ihnen von anfang schwer
franken muss so glaube ich konnte
beim co2 also immanente interpretation
noch ein stift ein bisschen stärker
man nennt interpretationen sollten sie
meine momente
das bedeutet dann dieselben begriffe
verwenden wie der die fehler suchen
verwenden
und das ist nicht gut das sollen wir
nicht mal das heißt wir wollen die bezug
dazu wollen wir eine rekonstruktion
das bedeutet problemorientiert
und es bedeutet mit anderen begriffen
darstellen
grund nicht zahlt nicht dem duktus
folgen
damit meine ich die philosophien und
philosophen wir haben vor allem die
philosophie zu tun
die haben ein besonderes system im auge
sondern reihenfolge und wenn sie jetzt
dieser reihenfolge folgen dann sind sie
zum engern text dann geben sie nur
wieder das heißt wenn sie rekonstruieren
wollen müssen sie das können sie einmal
das pferd von hinten auf zu
dieses team auf den kopf stellen oder
man nur ein zugang eine sache besonders
das heißt sie verhalten sich frey
gegenüber dem system logik dass meine
konstruktion das heißt jetzt endlich
frei
mit meinem sich dass sie beliebiges
heraußen importieren aber dass sie nicht
nur ausgabe folgen
dass es sich kritische bürger zu fragen
[Musik]
genau da kommen jetzt gleich darauf die
frage ist also wie macht man wenn man
jetzt hier nicht diese begriffe dieser
philosophen direkt jetzt neben sollen
jetzt mal ein paar niveau
das ist ganz einfach zu hause arbeiten
sollen sich nicht wiederholen an der
eigenständigen termin der klassischen
deutschen so viel anregung von diesen
antwort sein kannst werden so habe ich
ein beispiel für diese eigentümlichen
begriffe internet anschauen nicht die
tourismus und zweites absolute hessen
solche eigentümlichen begriffe die
verstehen niemand versteht niemand
entziehen wenn sie mal einen forscher
der forscherin fragen verlässt sie das
absolut weniger maschinen usw gar nicht
schwierig das sind nicht grundsätzlich
also wir wollen stattdessen wir fragen
welche probleme steht dahinter das geht
nicht um die begriffe sind ein problem
jeder inter steht alles anders gesagt
auf welches problem ist tegels begriff
des absoluten eine lösung so müssen sie
erst nächstes jahr von begriffen von
probleme deswegen der begriff braucht es
notwendig dass man im rekonstruktion zu
steigen begriffen wird meint angebote
sind andere begriffe oder probleme auf
die
diese begriffe dieser eigentümlichen
beziehen können alle so zum beispiel die
vermittlungsfunktion bezogen zwischen
natur frei das ist wirklich ein recht
interessantes thema das problem der
dafür im verhältnis zu diesen allerseits
frei gewesen anders erzählt wir haben
biologische natürliche seite wie auch so
was wie shannon ganz später sagt in
diesen text den wir heute wissen eine
zeit der natur weil ich ganz überrascht
als ich diesen branchen und wir können
wir jetzt diese einheit dieser beiden
autoren die wir haben können wir jetzt
aufzeigen und da erscheint der trieb
seine funktion der vermittelt zu haben
das wäre zum beispiel für die
entspannendes ist richtig weil das thema
wären zum beispiel die bildungsmesse ist
wie können wir uns von klose naturwesen
in seinem vermeintlichen blicken sie
können uns umgestalten lieber goethe die
freiheitsentziehung ist dass die fans
jetzt können wir durch den drehpunkt als
verwesen betrieb hat immer seine
aktivität
aber wie können wir uns den damals
frisch
uns als verdächtig was ist denn auch
interessant ist die einheits look zur
industrie bist dann ist das stichwort
personale identität also wie können wir
durch den trieb diese über die zeit
persistenz das ist auch bei fichte zum
beispiel dass dabei viel auf einmal
richtig durch den betrieb 74 mit uns
identisch betriebe drücken unseren
charakter wir sind jetzt sogar angebote
systematischen um lebens genommen noch
viele angreifen
ein tipp von mir zu machen kein fehler
wenn sie sich auch die beliebte freiheit
gezählt weil der begriff der freiheit
klassischen deutschen philosophie
vielleicht der wichtigste
es sind große debatte darüber aber sagen
viele philosophen sagen meine
philosophie sind seine philosophie der
freiheit sagte das sagt schelling sagt
auch letztendlich kann sagen wir nicht
alle
natürlich kann man sich jetzt verfolgen
weil es dann konnte unser freiheitliches
genau zu stehen wenn es negative für
positive freiheit handlungswillen zwei
absolute freiheit
es ist da fängt dann schon wieder habe
der gift der freien entscheidung
schlüsselbegriff zeit um dieses denken
zu verstehen jetzt gebe ich mal ein paar
mögliche hausen zum beispiel könnten sie
versuchen die bildungs- und zündet wie
bei hertha das unmögliche vielleicht
noch ein bisschen ein weiter so kann
zuschlagen
der bildungsträger im gegensatz zur
mechanik beiwohnen pubertät in ihr ganz
stark von ziemlich einheiten frei halten
gehört es mit einem office neben es war
ein bisschen eine rein kants kritik der
technologie was fast kannten ihn heute
hat jetzt so viel betrieb geht nichts zu
tun
rheinberg streep theoretische
freiheitsrechte streep theoretische
freizeit schiller streep theoretische
fleiß und so weiter die machen da hängen
eine zange
das scheint mir gut geht eine gut
geeignete teams darunter chance haben
ja sie dürfen mit dem was er geschrieben
es sei ja man exklusive diese
einreichungen immer bewegung also wenn
sie jetzt da schon die haben sie mal zu
ein bis zwei seiten ihren gedanken oder
einen seite und wichtig wäre mir da mich
mit wiederzugeben sondern möglichen
gedanken kann was das problem hatte ich
das ganze nicht mehr so explosiv machen
dann zeugen sie auf ein paar dinge
achten immer schauen rating
berücksichtigt
sehen sie jetzt exklusiv verstehen
wichtig mir leid frage
laut kleben
danke
argumente
das sind ganz wichtige argumente haben
wenn sie ein problem erkannt haben dass
dieser text behandelt wird dann schließt
sich der gleichen argumentation wenn es
ein problem gibt muss es eine lösung
allerdings texte die wir lesen sollten
sie lesen als eine antwort auf ein
problem und sie sollten sich fragen was
für ein problem hieß es und welche die
text den antrag sind dann kommen sie
diese rekonstruktive der redaktions
haltung viel besser hinhalten haben und
das ist gar nicht so einfach zu erkennen
was für ein problem das sich dabei
angepasst und häufig mehrere das sind
ganz vilbel
wir sollten ein problem herausgreifen
und jedes problem isoliere und dann in
eigenen worten mit dem schiede
lösungsangeboten diese ebenfalls in text
heraus lesen müssen
nein zu einem ende zu bringen und ganz
wichtig ist mir die argumentation
das heißt wenn sie hier gibt es eine
lösung
ist sie zu der lösung kommen brauchen
sie verschiedene argumente
sie kommen nicht mit einem schlag zur
lösung soll die bauern verschiedene
schritt ihre glieder dieser hausarbeit
sollte sich an
diesen schritt die idealen sondern
unsere kinder kommen im idealfall wären
ihre hausarbeit so gegliedert dass sie
das die kapitel letztendlich gliederung
punkte dieses argument abhängen
das wer wird in der wirklichkeit so
genau aber dass sie einfach wissen wenn
sie die arbeit jeder soll in den
gliederungen logisch erfolgen also das
sollte aufeinander aufbauen
in einer folge diesen modus dass man mit
gedanken ich glaube nur so kann mir
wirklich die süddeutsche für sowie den
deutschen tourismus davor lädt entzünden
museum gestellt wird man schaut man sich
einen titel
wir haben es uns nichts als tages ist
heute anschaut was finde das absolut
damit kann ich einfach nichts anfangen
sagen viele zuschauer
man kann sie nicht verübeln man kann
diesen zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
nicht zum furchtbar
ihr habt eben kein zimmer das höre es
wäre kein gutes auge sondern muss das
ernst nimmt dann ist es nun diese
begriffe diese theorien den leuten klar
zu zeigen sich selbst
also um eine durch einige jahre der ehre
die ich doch mittlerweile schon auf dem
buckel haben
so erlangte betonte wie man am besten
fährt so schreibe ich auch meine ganze
aufsetzen so immer wieder merke ich habe
jetzt keine keinen schaden fokus der
fans zu weit
das merken dass vielleicht der frust so
weit ist dann können alle möglichen text
stellt für sie interessant sein
je enger der focus desto besser dann
sind nur wenige textstellen wirklich
relevant sie müssen sich das so
vorstellen wenn über das beispiel sie
befragen den text und wenn die frage
spezifisch ist dann gibt der text
gelernt resümiert die dann an der manche
stellen würde ich an zu leuchten
euro auf seite sohn so plötzlich nur das
wichtiger als das auf seite es uns daran
merken sie dass sie den text da sind
nerv getroffen haben
als er hört sich gewicht wird irgendwas
wird sich wichtiger das anders wenige
und dann sehen es gern an die richtige
frage stellt ist sie nämlich dem gelogen
nicht zu weit nicht so häufig ist das
problem
das ist so weiter
wieso experiment kann sich das auch
vorstellen diese naturwissenschaftliches
experiment sie stellen ja auch ein
naturwissenschaftliches experiment
fragen die natur zu formulierende frage
wenn sie die frage richtig formuliert
ohne antwort wollte eine guten gefolgt
von guten mester wenn sie fragen zu
stellen kommen sie müssen daten raus
kommt es nicht so dass es keine frage
wir brauchen informationen wirkstätte
wand ich halte das ist zum einen
vorschlag und ich mal immer als angebot
das sie begegnet werden dass immer ist
das schon ein kurzes explosives zur
seite kennen werden wo sie diese punkte
einfach ausdrücklich vorgesehen also um
was geht es dabei welches problem hat
dieser philosophieren ihrer meinung nach
im auge wie löste das beben
[Musik]
ja das kann man machen man muss ja immer
so ein bisschen aufpassen mit zur
aktualisierungs versuchen weil man dabei
häufig unter dem niveau des textes
geleitet das ist meine erfahrung die
texte die wir hier lesen sind so tief
und so gehalten dass es im prinzip das
heißt wir finden nur wenige aktuelle
themen die diese texte herausforderungen
können man könnte es höchstens so machen
das 1 inwiefern haben diese text uns
angesichts diese neue entscheidung was
zu sagen aber ich bin immer so ein
bisschen skeptisch gegenüber solchen
aktualisierungs müssen weil ich glaube
wenn man den text wirklich rekonstruiert
und auf probleme transparent machen dann
ist dieser text dadurch ca
weil wir sind eigentlich in der
philosophie nicht mehr weitergekommen
als die klassischen deutschen suchen was
die tiefe gezogen
das haben sie vielleicht neue probleme
geben zb digitalisierung verstehe ich
ganz wirkung fragen theologische frage
ob es technische fragen nach dem
zusammenleben von individuen oder auch
massengesellschaft
so was hatten die klassischen deutschen
philosophie das wäre die möglichkeit
aber müsste dann das sehr genau zeigt
dass diese probleme der aktualität
damals noch nicht erkannt werden
so kann man es dann konfrontiert aber
was du tiefe die messung anteilscheine
diese texte unüberbietbar originell und
gehaltvoll dass also die allerwenigsten
heute in geschriebenen philosophischen
werke können denen das wasser reichen
was den philosophischen gehalt haben was
ihm heute gewerke besser können
das liegt auch anfang an der aktualität
ist dass die probleme klar der
hersteller viele probleme die die
damalige philosophen behandelt hatten
sind für uns heute nicht mehr so ein
problem haben zum beispiel die ganze
biologischen fragestellungen
kennen sie die neue biografie von
flieger safranski behörde du kannst du
mal gesehen oder gelesen also kann ich
ihnen viel glück dass afghanistan
schalter das eben immer auch ein
bisschen ja vor dem hintergrund seiner
direkt geschrieben hatte der einheit von
bild ich kann man später riesen risiko
schwer und begriffe welt das ist in der
welt
versöhnung ist theorien wie kann ich das
individuum mit dem ganzen versöhnen
ja das ist vielleicht heute zukommen
werden den man in romantisches der jesus
vielleicht fremd dennoch glaube ich kann
selbst bilder die diese romantiker noch
systematischer fragen stellung
heraus rekonstruieren und das ist die
hand zu zeigen da gibt's probleme
systematisch dingfest zu machen sind und
die nicht bloß so eine komische
alemannia aus einer kommode oder so dass
die demokratisch diese damen zahlen und
das muss irgendwas aktuelles in dem
seinerzeit das ist ein zeitvertreib es
nicht das ist jetzt nur für unsere
heutige mode sondern es ist einfach
insofern relevant als unser denken als
solches oder uns als menschen sind diese
tiefe strukturen was machen sie immer da
richtig werden sie auf bestimmte
begriffe der familie eine spielerische
freiheit ist also extrem zäh und auch
sehr wichtig wird uns neben als weil wir
sie verstehen müssen
es gibt natürlich jetzt die eine
bestrebung uns als die tiere zu denken
aber seht das provoziert muss im fall
swissair also freiheit wichtiger brief
sicherlich auch erkenntnis wichtiger
punkt nach was können wir wissen
kollegen die klaxons erkenntnissen
freiheit erkenntnis dass man
subjektivität können unsere identität
aufrechterhalten zeit was macht uns zu
uns selbst so ein charakter
bei all diesen pfad ist der trip zu
entscheiden
aber viel wichtiger wie sie bereits
gesehen
betrieben habe praktischen griff hat
kann man sie sonst nicht kein problem
gehen weiter jetzt machen wir für einen
kurztest und jetzt dürfen sie erst
einmal die chance ist und er hat jetzt
hier eine form der rückseite 8 fr
dafür haben sie jetzt mal 15 minuten
zeit vielleicht schafft er schneller
es gibt immer mindestens eine richtige
antwort möglichkeit es kann aber auch
mehrere wichtige abrunden ich kann es
geht sagte keinen fall der unter wo alle
antwortmöglichkeiten falsch sind als ein
oder mehrere sind
und wir schauen nach der auflösung
die nachfrage ist ein bisschen typisch
saniert und bewusst zu gemacht
dadurch dass sie gern mal ein bisschen
bisschen etwas großes problem
die schaltet in dem online dazu dass die
zuschauer hier auch den
machen können das sieht ja
schon werde ich auch sehr gut
haben sie noch ein bisschen zeit haben
sie es ja da können wir jetzt eigentlich
weil wir schon mal hier
sie haben sie auch hier also welche der
folge bitte verstehen oder systematisch
ja machen selber vorschläge ordentlich
zu werden einfach aus ihren appetit das
aus dem zettel
angst wie viel
naja
ja
[Musik]
welt s
also in der angst für die ihnen hier
also ich würde jetzt nicht nehmen also
ich glaube alles ist der zweck oder auch
hier der angst in der der staat aber
nichts ist er etwas gerichtet
wenn wir der angst fliegen dann fliehen
denn elvis konkretes hin
das machen wir der furcht durch das
konkrete der angst wollen wir auf dem
weg
es wird es hier nicht
ja also es war jetzt groß und trick von
mir jahres teilzunehmen
was würden sie sagen wenn ich jetzt hier
noch hunger einen appetit wollte
eigentlich immer setzen würden
[Musik]
so ist es auch bei energie ist eine
bestimmung auch etwas kosten zu lassen
schließlich ist er ist
ja so könnte man szenen aus
essen haben richtig
[Musik]
beide richten also ich wurde wird eben
nur sagen wenn sie jetzt sagen wo das
leben ich will hunger hunger voraus und
irgendwie uns appliziert und dürfen wir
auch nicht neigung eigentlich reinigen
weil nach kant ist gehalten was von
außen kommt
ich würde diese überlebenstrieb 100 das
sagen haben ich würde jetzt nicht rein
und genommen haben wurden ins all ist
neben überall immer wie mir scheint
nicht so richtig gerichtet ist
man kann es als sei ich habe zwar darauf
und damit nur in zwei etappen benzin
riecht
und sie sich etwas bestimmt die wollen
einfach nur etwas ist weil ich irgendwas
dieser art aber mir scheint dass immer
eine gewisse konzentration zu infizieren
und das ist halt bei begehren der fall
das ist halt meine haltung der fall
petit appetit heißt ja nur wieder das
kommt an der tiefen genau ist von apg101
scheinbar hat sich in deutschland seit
dem ja alles von vorn und peter wehr
heißt strebt
genau kein pr gag waren es in der
konzern könnte es ein beliebig und peter
wird alles ganz einfach nur man strebe
werden als träger streben streben abbas
ganz konkret nur habe ich vielleicht
schon ab was aber nicht zu konkreten
werden sie sagen ich habe jetzt appetit
das ist was anderes als 70 hatte zu
machen sagen wir ich habe appetit auf
irgendwas richtig habe zugenommen immer
auf mein bauchgefühl jetzt durch was ist
mit all das ist jetzt nur dass die
beiden eine feine kleine unterscheiden
aber ich glaube ja die überprüfung sich
ist ja ich bin schon so weiter wo er
besteht dieses thematisch persönliche
bedeutung von doppeldeutigkeit des cebit
nein
sie müssen
ja
so richtig kann es ja ziemlich fragen
für die youtube zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer scheidung im beschreibungstext
kann man den test online machen auf
ihrer tief flog auf als gewöhnlich
runtergeladen haben können sie dieses
nach
sie ist es den thron
sie können hätte uns sein sie müssen
sich zahlen deswegen ist die antwort
ebenfalls theorie bis in teltow nach
country behinderung aber nachrichten
können und nach schüler haben und nach
den meisten anderen audio wenn man
triebfeder noch mitzunehmen da gibt es
eine triebfeder 8 und wieder kann wie im
gerade im fall von autonomie ist sie
trägt also betriebe darf und dass die
freunde des seminars das neue betrieb
als freiheits manifestationen denken
kann sogar wilberg scanndy professor
jahr kommt der hier werd auch immer
diesen augen interessant werden locker
und geschrieben
der trieb als zyklisches phänomen
verpflichtet und werden bekannt trieb er
das ergebnis war so etwas moralisch
anstößiges war wird er bei fichtel
inbegriff wie in unserer freizeit also
einem sondertrikot weiter wie verwendet
herr der philosophische trieb
ja
[Musik]
perfektionismus wissen sie was das heißt
perfekt also vollenden lateinisch und
das ist ja weiter aus dass das ganze zu
verhindern wodurch es nach uhlbach der
bildung street passiert
ja
welche der folgenden aussagen treffen
auf kanzler sophie zu
ja
weil du sonst noch
sie haben noch nie
ja so was mal probiert so richtig zu
welchen der folgenden aussagen treffen
die welche folgen aussagen treffen und
freunde zurück
ja
weil interpretiert kannst dir treten
insel vertrieben
richtig vorherzusagen welche erfolgen
aussagen des coupe zu
das hatten wir vorher muss er sich was
sagt jetzt diese systematisch also jetzt
frage zu welcher von außerhalb seiner
philosophie zu
in der zeit sollen die pillen gefunden
22 sind geht zu ihnen jemand der von
enten gehört hat jemand alle sie können
gerne noch mal zu hause machen bestanden
haben sind alle schreibt sind gerne die
kommentare sie hier
aber auch die zuschauerin zu schauen ob
sie probleme zu diesem problem mit die
einzelnen fragen hatten
das ist sie irgendwie plausibel frei
oder wir nicht so jetzt schon für ich
mich hier ein bisschen zurück und jetzt
geht es hier wieder alte zwar mit uns so
eine folie den haben sie erfolgreich für
die digital teilnehmer können sie mit
mir
lukas ist klebt es mann oder und sie
können geschäfte sind so jetzt dass hier
in china ein schlüsseldienst schätzen
warum kleinen rückblick aber eigentlich
haben sie ja dass hier schon gewusst
doch alles so schön sein zwischen
informant stoffen ins spiel treten nicht
zwischen einem erkenntnis trieb an den
praktischen ästhetischen tv richtet dann
mehr aus dem boden stand hatten wir hier
gelesen
damit formuliert er die kantige toni
fink fehler wäre ähnlich wie wright und
ein hund hatte von einem eigenen zimmer
- richtig geschwungene kanten der
schwierig ist aber noch schlage ich gar
kein richtiger twitter tweet neben dem
raumschiff ist in der favorisierten
modell beschreibt nur den zustand der
harmonie zwischen beiden trieben und
zwar nimmt das schüler eine höhere
notwendigkeit diese hilfe höhere
notwendigkeit werden sie auch bei shell
immer wieder auch da müssen aufpassen
höher road wenn dich das sollen dass das
schild betreten
wieder so ein begriff notwendigkeit
heißt und ein
das ist gerade nicht freiheit ist aber
das spiel erfahren wir uns doch nicht
als notwendig trieben spielt erfahren
musste als freiwillig sagen geht es mir
aber beispiel das spiel an spielen
nachdem diesmal spielt musste am sicher
gefühlt bisschen vielleicht mitunter
selbst wenn man so ein bisschen tore
schießen möchten wollen verhalten sich
wie hat sich dabei für uns sein
als sie alle spieler halten das augen
der hand ja ja gut es ihnen spaß macht
man spiele können auch nicht spaß zu
haben
wenn sie zum beispiel nicht tag
sie würde es den osten und greifen
haben sie denn empfinden das hinspiel
ist ja leicht als anrede machen stars
als eine erfüllung als eine
herausforderung als eine art test als
anbieten kann
sie können sich aber andere spiele
spielen das anders spielen gedanken
spielt da sind sie auch sehr frei tritt
lebens assoziieren
wie wäre es neben ihm bei
gedankenspielen das spiel kann die
möglichkeiten nicht könig wer des lebens
könnte doch anders als diese möglichkeit
[Musik]
genau
so habe ich das interpretieren meine
doktorarbeit zum beispiel die höhe und
wendigkeit ganz anders im spiel keine
regeln zu beachten sind also die meisten
studien fußball hat wegen abseits aber
ich darf mich einfach den ball mit der
hand nehmen werden kann
16 befindet wenn es den bestimmt
aber diese regeln sind nicht so zu
verstehen im spiel fußballspiel dass
sich dadurch frei band gegenteil diese
regel machen wir's treiben und im
idealfall berücksichtigt diese regel ist
so sehe ich hab so verinnerlicht dass
sie verschwinden dass ich sie gar nicht
mehr merken dass erkennen sie bei ganz
tollem künstlerinnen künstler zum
beispiel deren kunstwerke die wirkt
geradezu fast schon regelmäßig kunde für
mit aber sie bemerkten diese regeln
geben werde
wenn sie jetzt eine pianistin oder
juristen hören dann wird die das so
leicht wo kommt dass sie gar nicht mehr
daran denken welche regel mehr zu sagen
das
als man könnte sagen die regeln sind zur
eigenen natur so als würde man
wendigkeit bedeutet irgendwie trotz der
regeln trotz der bestimmung oder
schlecht ist wie jetzt gibt es dann zum
beispiel von henry folgen würde
sie beziehe ich mich immer gerne hilft
der branche
zwischen und ersetzt die willentliche
als wenn sie jetzt eine entscheidung
getroffen
nennen sie jetzt lange überlegt haben
wie soll ich denn jetzt machen und dann
sollen punkt kommt sagt genauso nicht
anders das ist die lösung so machen dann
sagt hermann für dann zieht sie es im
zustand der bullishen angesetzt
und sind sie eigentlich fühlst dich
schon gesehen aber nicht von außen
sondern sich selbst dann ist dieser
entschluss diese entscheidung so kräftig
und so am krieg man kann es also trieb
sein dass sie ihn unbedingt eine
handlung folgen lassen wollen
dieser zu steine inneren in china eine
zuspitzung des wollens auf eine konkrete
handlung das kann eben auch als
notwendigkeit bezahlt sonst in social
personen haushalt das ist eine solche
treffen
anders gesagt dass sie sich fragen wie
was soll denn konkret und da kann es
nicht schaden auch meine literatur von
zurufen mit hinzu hier in münchen ist
man da sehr dahinter dass diese summe
analytischen philosophie zu verbinden
das anderen bereich kommt ein gutes
deutschland aus mitteleuropäischen
gleichkommt und verschiedene
verwerfungen historische ort und zeit
wirklich zu flüchten und so weiter aber
die angelegenheit in österreich und in
deutschland pflegen mit dem stand solche
leute aber das ist dann eben später
darüber sehr ausgefallen oder vertrieben
haben
sie sagen und dieser mythischen
philosophierende philosophen zeichnet
ihn aus dass gegenüber solchen begriffen
eher skeptisch
und da sind die versuchen erst an zu der
frage ich glaube da kann sich bei stefan
nehmen indem man immer versucht sich
ganz konkret zu machen auf den frage in
sitzen dann was der analytischen
philosophie
dabei hatte mit dem ist einfach die
große tiefe klassischen deutschen
philosophie kommentare europäische
philosophie macht diese tiefe geht sehr
schnell aufräumen wenn man sich nur auf
diese logischen formalen struktur passt
deswegen das beste aus beiden welten
personen für münchen zu sammeln zu den
analytischen methoden um die ganz großen
gedanken
ja sogar zwei stunden
klarer geht also in dem es einfach klar
bekommt wenn er wie gesagt gerade zum
beispiel richtig und wichtig das sind
außer begriffe wie höhere notwendigkeit
was ist eigentlich und noch schlimmer
oder schwierige rechtliche das will ich
ja nicht mehr weiß was ehrlich ist ist
das selbstbewusstsein das ist mein
körper was ist es was man nicht ist es
die ausbildung über ich also meine ich
das also dass ich gerade schon bei der
begrifflichkeit ansetzen und die
einfache fragen der ausgabekurs zu
formen
ich glaube da haben sie schon diesen
analytischen gestus im petrus schon
beliebt wenn sie sagen ich muss man in
kirchen und klöstern ich muss eine
begriffsklärung in welchen kontext
verwendet wird überhaupt das nicht man
redet er von ich und wie ist dieses
films ist es bewusstsein selbst
wie muss es verstehen damit schon vier
seien einfach diesen der hand ließ sich
die begriff also selbstverständigung und
nehmen und es hat in der vergangenheit
durch gemacht werden sind wirklich
unsinn geschwister das absolute und
essig und die direkt kommentieren
damit ist also noch nichts ist freiheit
des goldes die version optimal stetig
ganzen mussten reformen frei
bild eine art usw das war nicht immer
diese problemorientierte
das leben nach
hier
so können wir jetzt auch in der mitte
spielen sagt schouten ist auch schiller
eben diese richtung das ist das tippen
gesetz ist mir irgendwann zimmer eine
natur und das sittengesetz die forderung
der pflicht stehen möchten als das
fremde sind gegen den kategorien wird
hier sind ich habe es erinnert sich ich
hab s ich habe nur jugend ausgemacht
und dann könnte man das aufatmen da ist
sehen sie durchaus frei und der
interpretation
aber wichtig ist einfach von diesen
gehilfen erstmal weg zu haben
und da kann man sich wirklich solch
analytiker gut vorstellen wieder einfach
die stille [ __ ] und sagen
verstehe ich dieses verstehe ich es
häufig sehr darf und kann es dann ganz
genau dem erklärte merkt dass uns auch
nicht so stehen lassen sich einfach
hinter diesen begriffen so ein bisschen
auch versteckt und die mit hilfe des als
schutzschild so wie es medien
da dürfen sie sehr gerne sehr
selbstkritisch gezeigt und jetzt
vorsichtig sein
der spieltag ist kein frieden leben den
anderen rufen
das habe ich hier wieder so ein begriff
gemacht profil
ein schöner begriff ist erst drei
bedeutungen es gar nicht genauer
eingehen
aber dann muss ich wohl so vorstellen
als wir haben hier den vortrieb stoff
dreht
die sehen sich entgegengesetzt film auch
komplementär und dann haben wir jeden
spieler müssen verstehen und nicht dass
man hier oder hier den spieltrieb auf
der serie jeden an
sie spielt liebt der gibt den ganzen
diese einheit und das ist dann auch die
höhere notwendigkeit und da sehen sie
natürlich dass schiller da schon auf
eine spur zu regeln ist
schiller das können sie bei rüdiger
safranski nachlesen sehr gute biografie
über china china china gegenüber den
immer erst mal im gegen die heutige zeit
und die vergangenheit also die artikel
und die heute so denken geben setzen
häufig auch in und schadstoffen gebe
setzen
das ist wirklich ein problem diese
maschinen und dann bestehen sondern
versuchte man das vermitteln das ist ja
das land das gesetze nach riegel these
antithese
und dann habe ich denken schon weiter
das ist so seien theoretisch
[Musik]
genau da gibt es hier
genau als nicht nur absolut individuell
das kurze einfach widerspreche ich
generell so schildert es gibt auch ein
zitat von hegel
das siegel sagt das schürt das problem
der subjektivität gefunden habe
häufig eben auch keinen vorlauf als uns
lieb ist nun dass objekte nicht die
einheit und da ist schildert durchaus
sehr okay so geht es jetzt das
josef so um ihr jetzt dass er
ältere der alte geräte gut bei places
ist dagegen
genau das ist der stern gemacht sehr
geboren bist aber der geburt gestorben
ganz genau
alles schien bis in die sozialen
einstellungen diese jahreszeit nicht so
wichtig aber dennoch helfen sie uns sehr
diese dinge im verhältnis also schilling
ist geboren
70 und gestorben ist 18 54 ist als 10 19
und
und sie wollte pohlig
tippen sie machen ist er geworden
deutschland als in deutschland enorm
süden ja vorher studiert bis zehn jahre
genau so war es
genau als näherungswert das heißt ich
jetzt nicht aus stuttgart kommen das ist
dann eben friedhofes kellinghaus
wenn sie mal in leonberg ist
sitzenbleiben ist das museum das ist
leicht bei der kirche ich heiße direkt
an der kirche dran ist weiß schilling 1
fahrers zum war wie so viele damals der
durch die touristen ja alles ein
protestantischen glauben pietistischen
protestantischen in die schüler jetzt
nicht und sagt sein vater war
obstbaumeister also adligen in
deutschland herzog ich weiß nicht
gemeint war der angestellten aber wir
wollten zum beispiel früher als kleiner
junge wollte er unbedingt fahrer bilden
es schallt aus safranski glaube ich
jedenfalls kann es geografisch nachlesen
karten ausspielen hatte sich cancellara
und seinen schwestern redeten und wenn
sie jetzt dieser bands die wir wie immer
höherer den krisen werden sie
feststellen würde genau dass selbst
seine mutter kumpel
das leopard-team kommt aus lauffen
neckar alles ganz in dem wieder
verlieren und phoenix noch hebel genau
hier kommt aus stuttgart und hegel
natürlich auch der möglich studieren und
war dabei wirklich der beste nicht der
jahrgangsbeste deswegen konnte er nicht
um den technischen diensten und was hat
man die macht wie alle michelle den
behörden genau hauslehrer ohne auch
nichts wenn man es damals gemerkt hatte
von der kommt michael reinhold lenz gibt
es ein stück das heißt einen meisten
rassen meister und meinen hof weissagen
einer hofmeister das war die stelle der
theologen häufig dann wird die studie
die ihre regierung werden konnten oder
wollten lieber philosophen sein
diese ersten anruf meisten hofmeister
einberuft wehrt sich und arbeiten häufig
bei wohlhabenden familie waren
deren kinder unterrichten mussten und
häufig beim essen als letzte das essen
bekommen haben sie haben also mit am
tisch
sie wollen wie das fünfte rad am wagen
also schlechter behandelt hat des films
gegeben weil das häufig als sehr
wohlhabend den familien im rang häufig
runter aber es waren sehr stolz den
hofmeister und sie wussten auch meine
zeit kommen muss jetzt hier durch
mediale schafften dann ganz viele war
das auch so hegemann schweiz werden und
höhere gewalt ist sie frankfurt ja und
dann hätte man auch in frankfurt später
als ministerin die hat situation in der
menschen gegen den verschlag auch
fichtenhof meisten hat über den
unterricht hat ein schüler ganz
geschickte eine 35 beigebracht erst
dadurch hatte sie gelesen und dann ist
es so begeistert über das was du
geschrieben dass sie das alles in ganz
ähnliche konstellation jedes geboren
wissen sie sicher wissen sie wann
geströmt
ich glaube 833 muss man auch eigentlich
wissen als sie sehen
schilling war fünf jahre jünger war habe
der noch immer viel weiter als die
chemie hat lieber gleich sehen wollen
können ihr 1800 schon sein system ist
tanzen gewesen
er hat hegel gerade seine ersten
versuche in frankfurt und damit mehr
oder weniger ausführliche rezensionen
kritik des vision system sonst
das waren eigentlich eher so kritiker
aber die wirklich eigenständige ansätze
kein system während darstellen schon
völlig ausgearbeitet
sie schaffen
klar das stück das stimmt aber er war
dennoch also eine von mit wurfs
charakter hier die werke wie die auftrag
schriften ist noch für das prinzip zu 98
91-sieg da war der 20
das prinzip ist natürlich auch wichtig
aber es die alten versehen und ekel hat
seine werke erst in den zähnen zwanziger
geschrieben dass ein wirklich gut ist
die logik 17
sie hatte glaube ich 1818 107 sehen da
hatte shell im schulsystem
da die technologie des geistes von
hegels viel bedeutet auch als das system
das transparente das muss arbeiten wir
viel also nur mal so als hintergrund das
kann zu wissen so exkurs zu jetzt müssen
wir dafür tags kommen heute in der
sitzung besteht das stimmt schelling
betrieb die familie und liebe zueinander
die fernsicht und freiheit
wir fragen wir lesen jetzt im
hauptabschnitt des systems ist
transzendent idealismus man das system
der praktische philosophie
nachdem kurz ins transzendente
hier steht natürlich wie satin kannte
minogue und fichte sind jetzt keine
leichten textabschnitte gerade wenn sie
hier die aufgabe sehen wodurch dem ich
das wollen wieder objektiv werde
liebe güte erstmals ist dass ich das
wissen also ungefähr dass es objektiv
was könnte damit meinen dass dem nicht
das wollen wieder objektiv werde
hoppla
so kann man es verstehen ihren dem dass
ich eine sms geschickt
genauer ist als zum beispiel wenn sie
jetzt das mal überlegen was wir haben
jetzt hier
[Musik]
zum objekt
ja und dann das bedeutet das dass ich
darauf reflektiert
da kann man jetzt wieder zum beispiel
von der analytischen philosophie
diese unterscheidung von eltern würden
wir sind darauf eingehen bei reinhold
kennt ihr das noch wirst oder als
koalition die justiz weiter
das könnte man aber lassen und eine
textseite entweder satz das worden
welche sich geständig und notwendige auf
ein größeres objekt also nicht wie sie
sagt mir jetzt auch nicht irgendwer
sonst noch was besseres
das wäre der apotheker brauchen betrieb
da sehen sie hier den vertrieb des
objektes angestrebt da ist er drin war
es durch den freien akt der
selbstbestimmung vernichtet das nicht
gleichsam alle materie seines vorstellen
dem es sich in ansehung des objektiven
völlig frei machen
und nur dadurch eigentlich wird das
wollen zum wollen dieses akts als
zeichen könnte das ich sich nicht
bewusst werden wenn eben das wohl nicht
abermals zum objekt wird dies ist aber
möglich und dadurch dass ein objekt der
anschauung sichtbarer ausdruck seines
wollen sind aber jedes objekt der
anschauung ist ein bestimmtes es müsste
also gut hieß es stimmt es seien nur
wahrheiten insofern dass ich auf diese
bestimmte art gewollt hätte dadurch
allein würde dass ich selbst ursachen
die materie ist alles vorstellen können
sie damit was anfangen
die mitglieder entscheiden jetzt mal
besonders so kann man versuchen merkt
sie dass man sich das ein schwieriges
zitat es erst mal nicht so viel klar und
das damit sind sie immer letztendlich
betroffenen zur klassischen deutschen
philosophie interpretieren es müssen uns
überlegen wie die begriffe sind jetzt
hier ganz zentral ja
wir haben jetzt hier schon eigentlich
was handelskonzern ideologie hier
anscheinend vorstellen ja und wir haben
von welcher disziplin feiern jetzt einig
diese bekommen diese begriffe in der
regel vorher genau auch als eigentlich
erkenntnistheorie köpft das ist
eigentlich noch sehr wenig jetzt alles
an praktische philosophie ist nach
solchen aussagen reflektieren kann
[Musik]
das impliziere dass ich genau genau das
ist glaube ich sehr sehr guter hinweis
das ist wieder dieser unterschied
zwischen dem trieb im negativen sinne
diesem hätten sinne und dem trieb als
etwas was autonom ist also einerseits
fühlen uns so etwas in betrieb wir
müssen aber herz sein dieses getrieben
sei wir müssen allen diesen trieb noch
mehr reflektiert damit er uns erkennt es
an denn sie haben wir verschiedene
neigen und rieben sich aber sie würden
nicht immer schon sagen dass sie sich
damit voll identifizieren müssen uns
auch identifizieren
wo genau es ist richtig oder falsch
so wollen sich genau wie ich glaube das
ist nun klar aufwand kommt also
reflexivität bisher stehen noch weiter
aber faire die handlung wodurch das
objekt dieses bestimmte wird darf nicht
absolut identisch sein mit dem probieren
selbst denn sonst wäre die handlung ein
blindes produzieren
ein kurioses ansteigen die handlung als
solche und das objekt müssen als
unterscheidbar bleiben ist aber die
anhörung als solche aufgefasst begriff
war begriff und objekt unterscheidbar
bleiben ist nur dadurch möglich dass das
objekt unabhängig von dieser hand am
existiert das heißt das objekt prothese
es ist umgekehrt wird hier das allergien
deswegen nur durch das wollen ein
äußeres das wollen ist wollen nur
insofern es sich auf ein unabhängiges
was wir jetzt hier nicht was an
problemen
[Musik]
die aufgehende und nebenklage
und dass die nation wissen dass sie
haben nur den satz bundes aber die
handlung als solche gefasst begriff
natürliches gibt inbegriff der handlung
ist meinte also meinte damit handeln
heißt begreifen
[Musik]
ich glaube so kann man sechs vorstellen
also vorher gedanken hat oder unseren
film zum konkretisieren ich brauche
einen begriff von etwas als an der
streifen klickt die begriffe muslime
davon machen und dadurch wird so
investierten erst ermöglicht aber ob das
die an großen ist ja genau
ja ich denke da muss man sich zum
spielen
also wir müssen jetzt endlich das objekt
als zu erstreben des auf konzept ohren
ziehen müssen uns darüber bewusst werden
was unser ziel ist ein ziel vor augen
diese formulierung des ziels zwecks das
leite gläubig entwickeln
[Musik]
des verfahrens grauens endlich kann ich
unabhängig von alban berg
haben und dass wir jetzt hier nicht
genau das möchte jetzt nicht also
richtig erst sagt hier sonst wäre die
handlung ein blindes produzierenden
kloses anschauen
ein guter hinweis diese trends and arlen
stanic bekannt das ist ja dass die
reinigung chancen des raumes und der
zeit und wir können das ist zum beispiel
intellektuelle anschauen anerkannt nicht
so ganz sicher ausgegeben für die andere
für die nach kannte stadt oder sofa ein
großes thema war schloss dahin
intellektuelle anschauen intellektuelle
anschauen ist bedeutet wissen sie was
bedeutet der begriff
das bedeutet dass wir etwas
hervorbringen
ab juni also unabhängig
april jüdisches hervorbringen von sind
nicht
und davon anschauen
das mag dieses intellektuelle also wenn
ich jetzt endlich selbst etwas
konstruiert hervorbringen oder dass ich
dabei ein versöhnliches das ziemliches
sind tierisch ist ziemlich ungehalten
schar anstiege kommen konkreten sinne
hervorbringen oder der sich darauf
angewiesen wenn auch die rezept inité
also sind es da die von außen kommen ich
muss ich selbst kann kennt natürlich
einige fälle wo es so etwas eben
es gibt zum beispiel dieser 13
die reine mathematik das ist für ihn so
dass die geometrie wäre das kennen
wissen sie was in der zeit ist derzeit
das ist dann eher kalt die arithmetik
die zahl mit wenn wir alle in der zeit
zu denkt dass ein anderer bereit
also nicht in der zeit jetzt aber als
empirische zeit sind als in eine
mannschaft
doch die dies die ganze welt aber es
wird wieder mehr überwunden weil wir
hier wieder symbolismus haben und was
letztendlich so alle journalisten
angetrieben hat war diese unterscheidung
von kantig sehr strikt ist etwas
aufzulockern kann also mehr gewinn das
kann sagt jan schaumann begriff müssen
zusammenkommen begriff dann haben wir
kenntnisse und dieses anschauung das ist
verkannt in der regel etwas was ein
apostel rio gekommen
wir haben zwar bei der anschluss doch
manche fälle probiert wer also eine art
intellektuellen haben eine konstruktion
wie kann das nennen reinschauen
aber wenn wir jetzt konkrete
erkenntnisse machen wollen dann brauchen
wir anscheinend von austern und die
deutschen touristen wenn uns das denn
möchte die paten versucht dieses moment
der anschauung in den begriff
reinzuhängen mehr oder weniger
erkenntnisse aus dem mit griff und sogar
feld ansteuerung aus dem weg selbst
zuerst
das ist natürlich sehr ambitioniertes
unterfangen das ist die höchste
steigerung die in rationalismus annehmen
kann denken empirismus interesse sagt
alle erkenntnisse in den aussagen von
der erfahrung von vorstellung die
schwache abbilder von eindrücken und
jetzt genau das gegenteil hier sagt
erkenntnis muss ein begriff ersetzt
schließlich irgendwie mehr als reaktion
von der erfahrung ist ein begriff ist
etwas was ja vor der erfahrung
da können sie uns ein bisschen klatsch
die dms geht so ein bisschen aber wir
sehen wir ein ganz schwieriges film
er möchte also nicht dass eine hand
lotion zu verstehen ist scheint mädels
hier falls sein wie eine intellektuelle
oder produziert das möchte er nicht für
die handlungen muss etwas äußerst also
eine handlung ist nicht mehr was im test
man muss etwas besseres geben als dass
sich hinstellen muss ich über mich ist
fast alles zu tun sagt er hier dass das
objekt unabhängig von dieser angst ihr
das heißt das es gibt natürlich bekannt
den fall dass wir das dir eine
praktische vernunft bekanntes sagt dass
die selbst uns motiviert die achtung
denken sondern diese aktuelle triebfeder
acht sondern vernunft bewirkt das gefühl
da ist die vernunft unserer
subjektivität immerzu möchte die wird
selbst den aktiven geben bringt schon
fast nahm sich franck die bringt die
objektive die verlegung das gute das
böse objekt erfolgt also das scheint
sich jetzt etwas dagegen dass er jetzt
schon was in der folge auf vollständige
erklärt wird warum das ich sich
schlechterdings nicht entscheiden kann
als ein objekt der substanz nach
hervorbringen warum vielmehr alles
hervorbringen wollen nur als an formen
oder bilder des objekts erschafft durch
unser beweis ist nun allerdings da getan
das gewicht das wollen
solches nur durch die richtung auf ein
äußeres objekt objektiven werden kann
aber es ist noch nicht erklärt woher
denn in richtung selbst kommt als er
bescheid zu sagen wenn überhaupt eine
umgebung zu haben etwas was der strebens
wert ist er strebt nach ist darf das
objekt nicht im ihr sonst wäre ich ja
bald werden wir es ins objekt setzen
das heißt es brauchen handlungen zu
dingen etwas alles was nicht aufgelöst
werden kann durch subjektive es wird bei
dieser frage schon vorausgesetzt dass
die produktive an john ford dauere in
dem ich will wurde dass ich in wollen
selbst bestimmte objekte vorzustellen
gezwungen keine möglichkeit kann wo es
entsteht also durch das wollen womit
bahrain gegensatz und dem ich durch
dasselbe einerseits der freiheit als
auch der endlichkeit bewusst
andererseits durch den zwang
vorzustellen ständig blinkt ähnlichkeit
zurückgezogen es muss also mit diesem
widerspruch eine tätigkeit entstehen
die zwischen unendlichkeit und
endlichkeit in der mitte schwebt wenn
diese tätigkeit des einbildungskraft wo
ist der kürze halber und ohne dadurch
etwa beweis behaupten 12 das was man ins
gemein einbildungskraft nennt sein
solche zwischen endlichkeit und
unendlichkeit schwebende oder was
dasselbe ist eine theoretische und eine
theoretisches und praktisches
vermittlungstätigkeit wie sich denn für
dies alles in der folge die beweis
fingern lässt die rouladen
[Musik]
aus
ich mache erst mal dass ich ihn mir dass
ich es in der selbstbewussten sind
geschlossen
ein ähnlich ist darf der kreis diesen
nicht gerecht würde
es gibt es einen widerspruch zwischen
diesen begriff der sich alle formell
kann um diese realität
[Musik]
ja genau
als hätten wir diese unterscheidung
zwischen patriotischem vorn anfangen dem
apostolischen demnach alle erfahrungen
die einbildungskraft ist genau hier drin
die einbildungskraft vermittelt zwischen
diesen zwischen anschauen gegeben und
dem inneren den begriff da muss einem
ein verhältnis hergestellt da gibt es
allerdings auch schon bekannt als der
bildungscard erkannt auch sehr wichtig
jetzt verschiedene formen der
einbildungskraft eine fixe örtlicher
bildungsgrad sehr kompliziert wie man
eben diese verschiedenen dinge dass
aperiodische verkäufliche und das
apostolische ist ziemlich jemandem
zusammen zu werke als die
einbildungskraft ist wie sie richtig
sagen vermittelt ist die sache weiter
jedes vermögen als was wäre das ein bloß
kraft film wird in jedem schrieben auch
notwendig etwas produzieren das selbst
zwischen unendlichkeit und endlichkeit
schwierig aha jetzt bitte noch
unendlichkeit ähnlichkeit es sagt die
freiheit sei die unendlichkeit
wie kann man diesen satz verstehen warum
ist denn die freiheit ein atemzug mit
unendlichkeit member maschinen
so könnte man sagen ja
inwiefern
hier habe das wäre ja lächerlich es
steht ja schon in endlichkeit aber sie
geht schon eine richtige richtung
ich würde sagen weil wir alternative
möglichkeit haben möglichst das muss
nicht so sein es könnte auch anders gibt
ganz viele möglichkeiten das ist glaubt
damit keine ahnung aber zum beispiel das
ist ein typischer satz wo man sich
fragen muss text kommen zwei ganz starke
griff ins spiel freiheit endlichkeit
zack ist erstmal gar nicht klar
dann müssen es versuchen einfach alles
geblieben durch das volumen und der
handlung einen dualismus zwischen dem
begriff dem subjektiven mann wurde man
zweck und dem objekt was aber auch als
etwas zu erstreben des auges außerhalb
von mir gedacht werden muss und mit
seiner ebenen dualität und jetzt bei
sofort schülern wieder was mittel das
jetzt hier angepasste produkte derart
sind was man ideen im gegensatz geht
begriffe und die einbildungskraft ist
eben deswegen in jenem schweben nicht
verstand und vernunft und die wiederum
was ins gebein theoretische fall ist ist
nichts anderes als die einfluss kraft
der freiheit und zeigt dass eine
schwäbin schweben ziehen schweben ist
die metapher auch bei solchen mittag
muss man sehr oft deutschland wissen wie
klassische durchsuchen liebe ist ne
taffe es glaube ich jetzt nicht ich
glaube dass die anziehungskraft ist sehr
beweglich extrem wirklich wie könnte man
es schweben doch verstehen genau als
ungebundene auch wieder in die die
freiheit des nicht gebunden sei es nicht
an der zeit das flexibel das dynamische
glaube es so dass vermittelt es aktive
das schwierig es ist diese dynamik im
vermitteln dass aber bloß das aber
ideenlos objekte der einbildungskraft
sein die nur in jedem schwebe zwischen
endlich können
die ich keine stellung erhält daraus
dass sie zum objekt des verstandes
gemacht auf jeder runde auf löslichen
widersprüche führen welche kantone den
baum der an die domain der vernunft
aufgestellt hat wir haben existenz
einsicht darauf beruht dass entweder auf
das objekt reflektiert wird in welchem
es notwendiger endlich ist oder dass
auch das reflektieren selbst wieder
reflektiert wird wodurch das objekt
unmittelbar wieder unendlich das dann
aber offenbar ist das wenn das objekt
eine idee endlich unendlich sein bloß
von der frau richtung der reflexion
abhängt das objekt selbst an sich weder
das eine noch das andere sein kann
so müssen diejenigen dem wohl produkte
der einbildungskraft das heißt einer
solchen tätigkeit sein die weder endlich
es noch ein endliches produziert also
jetzt jetzt ganzes land das hat
einbildungskraft als tätigkeit was
tätiger zwischen wirklichkeit und
unendlichkeit etwas vermitteln ist ein
dynamischer aber das ich sehen wollte
übergang von der idee zum bestimmten
objekt auch nur um gedanken machen denn
wie ein solcher übergang möglich sein
wird noch gar nicht gefahren ist nicht
zu begreifen wenn es nicht aber mal
etwas vermittelt es gibt was für das
handeln geben das ist was wir das denken
bei ideen das symbolen oder bei begriffe
des schemas dieses vermittelt
ist das sowas wie ideal ist natürlich
ganz ganz praktisch und jetzt kommen
noch zu guter letzt ultima vertrieben
durch den gegensatz zwischen dem ideal
und dem projekt entsteht dem nicht
zuerst entgegengesetzten zwischen dem
objekt ist vitalisierende tätigkeit
verlangt und dem objekt wie es die ihn
gezwungen denken darf ist also
äußerlichkeit wir haben das größere was
erst realisieren wir tun und wir haben
uns schon eine vorstellung davon wie es
sein soll eine zutat herzlich und dem
objekt wie es dem gezwungen denkt nach
ist durch diese entgegengesetzt habe
unmittelbar der trieb das objekt wie es
ist in das objekt wie es sein sollte zu
verwandeln in dem die hier entstehen
tätigkeit eintreten weil sie einerseits
frei und auch andererseits ohne über und
ohne alex
gefühle sprengt welches beide zusammen
im begriff das verdeckt wir haben jetzt
keinen zentralen taten beide möchte ich
jetzt aufgabe gehen sie mit diesen
fragen auf den bezieht er sich durch
ihre von den dingen die wir schon
abgeschalteten denke ganz sind alles
ja
genau
für ein
[Musik]
also ich glaube sie haben recht fichte
stetig und deckel sind praktischen
drehen da hatten wir auch die differenz
von auch in und ausland machen dass
diese wirklich mal interessant finde ich
jetzt hier
das schreibe mir auch ganz gut auf
dieses seminar team anzupassen
er sagt der trieb ist einerseits frei
andererseits wie nicht feiern oder drei
minuten gefühls der dich und das ist
diese ambivalenz die sich hier durch das
seminar thema zieht nämlich der trieben
zwischen freiheiten natur das scheint
den seychellen und auch zu reflektieren
das müssen wir nun leider schluss machen
die diskussion ist zwar eröffnet wie sie
hier sehen sie ist aber nicht
abgeschlossen in dem jetzt
ganz angenehm auch den betrieb sind
nicht bitten zu schauen und sich gerne
kräftig noch unter dem medium
mitzudiskutieren
weiters dass dann wünscht ihnen jetzt
noch eine festwoche und ich gebe ihnen
auf ihren kurzen ausblick auf die
nächste sitzung
wir machen hier böse blick schaut
manchmal ganz böse wenn es das ja genau
der teamkollege von schelling und eine
wer die nächste sitzung ein bisschen
schelling zuende besprechen und dann
aber wirklich diesen harten tobak vom
ergebnis